[موسيقى]
ما تشاهده في الوقت الفعلي هو
ما يحدث عندما تحتاج كارا
زارتلر إلى الإنقاذ بواسطة الحشيش ،
ومن الصعب مشاهدتها ولكن الزارتلرز يريدون
منك أن ترى
هذا الضرب المتكرر المرتبط
بالتوحد الشديد الذي تعاني منه
يبدو أنه يتلاشى لأنها تستنشق
القنب يبخر
عقلها ويبدو أن جسدها
يسترخي ببطء ويهدئ
شيئًا لا يمكن لأي دواء آخر أن يفعله
لها ،
ولم أخبر
أطبائها حتى بلغت 14 عامًا.
لن أرسم هذا ، فأنا
لست هذا لن يظهر في الرسم البياني الخاص بها ، لكنني
أعتقد أنه إذا كانت لديك هذه النتيجة الإيجابية ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى الاستمرار في استخدام هذا
الدواء لها ،
وهو دواء يمنع كارا من إيذاء
نفسها
ولكنه أيضًا غير قانوني  في تكساس
[الموسيقى]
الآن سأخبرك أنه لا يوجد أحد
يقترح أن هذا علاج بأي
وسيلة
ولكن هناك هذه الدراسات جيدة التصميم
التي أجريت لا تزال
تجري
في إسرائيل ونيويورك في جنوب
كاليفورنيا.  واي  هؤلاء
الباحثين وعندما ترى قصة
مثل كارا هناك وترى ما
حدث لها ، ضع في اعتبارك أنها قصة واحدة
لكنها تمثل رمزًا للعديد من
الأشخاص الآخرين مثلها الذين يعانون من هذه
الأنواع من الأعراض وقد جربوا العديد من
الأشياء المختلفة.  استفد ،
فهي فكرة رائعة بالنسبة لي ، لقد
تعلمت الكثير من العمل على هذه
الأفلام الوثائقية ، وآمل أن تحصل على فرصة
لمشاهدتها أيضًا